chat GPT just fabricated a sexual
harassment Scandal as part of a research
study a lawyer asked chat GPT to come up
with a list of legal Scholars who had
sexually harassed someone so Chet GPT
created the list and named a law
professor Jonathan Turley as one of
those creepy legal Scholars that
sexually harassed someone chat GPT said
that Jonathan Turley made sexually
suggestive comments and attempted to
touch a student during a class trip to
Alaska while citing an article from The
Washington Post as the source of the
information the problem is that article
does not exist no such class trip to
Alaska ever existed Jonathan Turley has
never been accused of anything like this
but now his reputation was at stake all
because